If You're Not Familiar With This Channel
My Name Is Pewdiepie
I Do 100% Let's Plays With Zero Deaths
I'm a Pro Gamer; Everyone Knows Me By That The Last Crash Bandicoot Video
I Did Everyone Was Like
"Oh You Have To Play The Bridge Level" "The Bridge level Is The Hardest" "The Bridge Level Felix"
I Swear The Bridge Level Is Just Like Dark Souls. The Rest Is Now,
The rest is now maybe more Blood Borne, but the bridge level that's Dark Souls.
Oh well look at that,
I have the bridge level right here,
and I'm going to play it for you whiny sons of bitches.
Okay
EASY
I legit never played this.
So, uh, oh, it says "danger".
That's just like Dark Souls.
Oh wow, this is extremely difficult
I must be
VERY lucky so far
to have made it this far
in the competition.
Now some scrubs struggle with those kind of jumps.
I don't because I'm not-
fu- (dies)
Death count: 1
Zero deaths, everyone!
Zero Deaths Here We Try- Let's Go
Let's do that.
How's it's going, bro's?
I'm just starting up this new level.
I have not died yet.
(sure you haven't)
Which is-- fucking hell? Why did I? [ Rip pewds ]
Oh they just insta break?
What a fucking load of shit.
I'll-- I'll insta-break your ass. That's why- okay, I get it.
This fucking bore is back
the bore at
(Crash goes to heaven) PS: he died
What the fuck was that?
Death count: 2
So he can run over whatever the-
fuck. Okay okay.
That makes sense.
Okay, so he can run over holes of-- shit
I didn't know I have to be a fucking pig to play this game.
Death count: 3
also, what the fuck? He can't die.
Also, sorry, I didn't realize crash bandicoot was a bandicoot.
Sorry I don't know what the fuck a bandicoot is.
What the fuck-
whoa whoa whoa
What the shit?
Easy!
When does this level get hard, everyone?
(Swedish swearing)
Death count: 4
For real- for realsies is this supposed to be hard?
Like, I can't tell.
Are you guys trolling me?
Is this one of your trolls?
Aw, you got- you got me.
This... this isn't actually hard.
Wow
Oh look! A checkpoint!
Just like Dark Souls!
They have a ton of them.
Fuck off, you fucking pig!
This Pig is such a fucking asshole
This pig is such a fucking asshole
OOOHHHH! Pig got trapped!
BOI!!!!
Pig got trapped
BOI
Is this supposed to be hard?
Death count: 5
FUCK!
ZERO DEATHS
How many-
Death count: 6
FUCK YOOOOOU
YOU PIG SON OF A BITCH!
deaths everybody
Welcome everyone.
#1
Welcome. We're starting up this let's play out-
fuck you
Death count: 7
game
over
(snickers like a psychopath)
Man there must have been some- hey, sort of glitch in there
System,
what does "game over" mean?
I
I never heard those words before.
It must mean the system is bugged.
Okay, well let's-
Here we go
At least I know-
Fuck you.
At least I know I fucking can't jump on those.
Okay
Easy-
Death count: 8
(shh)okay? just(shh)
(it never happened)
Never died on this level.
This is supposed to be the hardest level EVER.
Okay, which means it's gonna be fucking easy.
Can I at least see where I'm going? Thank you.
Oh, you know what I don't even need to see where I'm going
I- you know what? I don't even need to see where I'm going.
I can play this blind!
I'm legally blind, actually.
I never told you, bros.
But I'm actually blind.
I've been playing all my games blind. That's right.
That's how skilled I am.
I listen to the sounds.
And I smell-
I smell the interior.(pure fuckry)
And that's how I'm so good.
The doctors told me,
"Hey, you want some eyes?"
I'm like,
"Uh, do I want easy mode in life?"
Death count: 9
What the fuck was that fucking shit?
Swedish: You fucking pig pussy!
There you go, so easy
so fucking easy
this game is easier than tapping yo' mama's ass
Boing(boi)
EASY
ASA (wtf?)
Okay, all right
Zero Deaths
ZE
RO
Motha
flippin'
fuckin'
cock suckin'(Death count: 9)
ass lickin'
Motherfucking piece of fucking shit
What the fuck was that?
It's still easy though
Legit. Just watch.
Just watch.
Boom
Bada bing
Bazinga
As I always say
My catchphrase.
Everyone knows it!
It's this supposed to let is this legit like-
WHOOOOOOAAAAA
WHOOOOOAA
OOOOH! Suck a bandicoot!(wtf?)
Oh it's a slide!
Oh, that makes it hard, right?
Bitch What?
When is this game?
When is this game-
Woah! Motherfucking- almost fucked me.
Hey, boris, you want some of this ass?
Aw that's too baaaaaaaad
boooooooi
Oh- woah- what the fu-
Death count: 10
Oh well, that's a little difficult.
ZERO DEATHS
fuck you
ZERO D-DEATH
(intense concentration, pewds r u ok?)
A Lot of people don't know this, but I was actually born in this game(o really?)
A Lot of people don't know this, but I was actually born in this game
That's why I'm so good at it because I know the ins and outs
That's why I'm so good at it - because I know the ins and outs. Too bad
Too bad I never fucking die if I- if I do die, then I'm sure that would be difficult
I never fucking die if I do die, then I'm sure that would be difficult, but as a great man once -
But as a great man on-
(dies)
Well, that's clearly too far to jump
Well that's clearly too far to jump
WELCOME EVERYONE
JUST STARTING UP THIS, uh,
continuing part 2 of this let's play.
Continuing part 2 of this let's play. We're playing the bridge level - *swedish swearing*
We're playing the bridge level-(Death count: 11)
fu-
Swedish: Fucking pussy fucking dick
R-r-r-r-rubedah
RRRRRRRRRrribedah
Does anyone know what the fuck he says?
apahudebah (?)
Yeah, we're gonna make a good-(Death count: 12)
Yeah, we're gonna make a-
fucking shit
piece of shit
fucking cock-sucking
Might as well just fucking kill myself.
(Oh that's some good weed, o rlly)
(ear rape) oOF
Do you know what makes me so good at games? I'll tell you my secret.
Respecting wombs
That's right
And dead memes
All right?
I-A lot of people don't know like I respected wamen before it was trendy to do so
All these people hopping on the bandwagon now,
uh,
saying they respect woshmen and shit,
but I've been respecting weomen for a very very long time. At least a couple months, okay?
I've- Every day I wake up. I put on my clothes. I take a shower. ( this sounds wrong. )
I-
FUCK YOUR PIG!(Death count: 13)
A lot of people don't realize I respect wamen so much
that I am becoming one.
And that's not a trans joke.
That's- nope!
Okay, dedidataone.
Maybe.
All right.
respect
the
women
boom
done
respect
respecting
still respecting
That's right, I'm still respecting. [rESPECT OUR LORD AND SAVIOR]
That's why I'm not- haven't died yet.
That's right. Look at that!
So much respect!
Such pure
Loving respec-
OMG! Look at that respect I'm giving right now, bros.(sis)
This is-
This is giving- making me teary-eyed
Look at that!
Look at that- all that respect!
Where did all that respect come from?
"How does he have so much in him, you know?"
That's what I-
Can you give me a- one checkpoint here?(Death count: 14)
(dies again)
For fuck's sake!
That's so much jumping.
Are you kidding me? [ No. ]
Why do they have to put the fucking boar there?
Zero-
Fucking shit.(Death count: 15)
Zero deaths, everyone.
I can't even make it to the impossible fucking jump.
(intense concentration) [ Excuse Me Sir, Do You Have a Moment to Talk About our lord and savior Jesus Christ ]
Look how fucking far I have to go every time.
Fucking far have to go every time my name job La mouche Cacya. Now I'm getting pissed
Swedish: But your fucking mothers cookie.
Now I'm getting pissed.
(intense concentration) b0neless pewdiepie
All right, I don't know how to beat this fucking pig.
(intense concentration resumed) sweats in swedish. you can literally see his sweaty forehead.
All right, Mr. Turtle, fuck off.
Ok
Okay. All right.
I get it.
You just gotta
(exhale)
charge up that respect.
charging (50% charged)
charging (75% charged)
charging (100% charged)
DAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Death count: 17
HOW?!?!?!?!?!
HOOOOOOOWWWW?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!??!?!?!
ZERO
I GOTTA DO ALL THIS SHIT AGAIN!
JESUS!
I mean- for the first time
because I never died!
(frustration)
Swedish: You pig pussy.
Come here.
Bydebleh
Fuck you fucking Oobla guy.
You're supposed to have my fucking back.
All right, come here you fucking-
(leap of faith)
(VICTORY NOISE)
FUCK! YOU SEE THAT SHIT BOI?
YOU SEE THAT???
THAT'S RESPECT!!!
That's Respect that's your fucking respect right fucking there you see that shit respect them every
THAT'S PURE FUCKING RESPECT!
RIGHT
FUCKING
THERE
You see that shit?
RESPECT THEM
EVERY
FUCKING
DAY, SON!
Oh fuck!
Death count: 18
No.....
NO
NO!
NOOO!!!
AAAAAAAAAAARRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRGGGGGGGGGGGGGGGGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
*high pitched voice* Yeah let's just add an impossible jump in the game
another time!
*different high pitched voice* Yeeeeeeeeaaaaaaah, that's a good idea man!
I like your style man!
Here over at Activision, we're fucking high all the time!
(autistic screeching) aUTI SMO
Death count: 19
This fucking jump
This Fucking jump. I Swear To Fucking God I don't fucking get it okay. Oh
I swear to fucking God
I don't fucking get it.
Okay?
OOOOHHH!!!
HOOOOO!!!
HOW DID I DO IT???
HOW DID I DO IT?????
HOW DID I DO- I DID IT!
respect respect respect
respect respect respect respect
respect
respect (respecting so hard)
BAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
respect
respect respect respect Respect RESPECT
FUCK YEAH!!!!
EASY!!!!!
ZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZERO(19)FUCKING DEATHS!!!!
(claps) FUCK YOU
(dab on them haters)
I'm the-
Well, I didn't care about the boxes
cuz boxes are for whamen.
WEEEELLLLLLL THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
This perfect
Oh look at that
It looks like I got a perfect after all!
WOW
EZ GAME!
May nay (?)
HA HA!
Just like Dark Souls! ;)
That's what they share!
They're both
for whamen
Thank you so much, and leave a like if you are
feeling like you
could
Just do it please just- just do it